you get more out of reading one book  that's great five times than out of  reading five mediocre books if your  behavior doesn't change as a result of  reading a book and it means you learn  nothing which means it was a waste of  time and many people who read books are  just wasting their time because their  behavior doesn't change and so I  consolidate once I find something that's  good I plug everything I possibly can  into it and suck the juice out of it so  that I can change my behavior as a  result which comes from the Frameworks  and how I think about it so I read one  thing that's very good many times rather  than trying to brag about the fact that  I read a book a week because I'm like  what was the book last week not that  good that it wasn't worth rereading